bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors il ya eu
d'abord ce sommet africain sur le
financement de la croissance africaine
c'était le 18 mai maintenant cette mini
tournée au rwanda et l'afrique du sud
et puis on sait qu'à l'automne il ya un
rendez vous important ce sera le sommet
afrique france
d'abord ce que sept agents d'adp
emmanuel macron il est réalisé avec
minutie planifié avec minutie c'est loin
d'être un hasard on l'imaginé et quels
sont les objectifs affichés mohammedia
tas je pense que les visites au rwanda
et en afrique du sud participe d'une
stratégie globale que emmanuel macron a
mis en place celle de l'art et des
finitions delà de la relation de la
france et l'afrique
et je crois que il a très bien commencé
en se rendant au rwanda pour essayer de
solder un passif assez lourd il y a fait
un mea culpa que vont penser impossible
de la part de la france et je crois que
ce mea culpa été très bien reçu par paul
kagamé lui-même mais aussi par les
rondes est donc en géant en général en
substance est vraiment devrait définir
la relation entre la france et l'afrique
pascal airault bas je voudrais vous
entend d'ailleurs sur la jante à que
j'avais évoqué mais sur le mea culpa ce
que c'est le mot qui convient le terme
qui convient parce qu on a plutôt eu
l'impression qu'en fait emmanuel macron
abondé dans le sens des deux rapports
sur le génocide la responsabilité de la
france
le rapport français le rapport rwandais
je vais répondre à votre première
question je pense qu'il a trouvé deux le
ton assez juste il y avait une équation
politique intérieure aussi à prendre en
compte le traumatisme du génocide de
1994 est encore vif
en france on voit bien qu'il ya diverses
chapelles il y avait des militaires en
opération il ya aussi une responsabilité
politique
à l'époque il fallait qu'il trouve les
mots justes pour à la fois touché les le
coeur des rondes et ce que je crois
qu'il a réussi à faire quand on voit la
réaction de paul kagame
qui a parlé d'un discours de vérité qui
a parlé du risque politique avait pris
ma cran et je pense que sur la scène
intérieure il a réussi aussi ça c'est
quand est-ce que même les plus critiques
à l'égard de paul kagame ont dû
encaisser le rapport duclair et ils se
sont même réapproprier un petit peu ce
rapport en disant qu'il n'y avait pas eu
de complicités françaises et pour eux
c'était le plus important parce que
politiquement cela permettait de les
blanchir pendant cette période un peu
douloureuse
quant à votre première question je pense
que monaco va très bien pensé sa
politique africaine depuis le début il
s'est inscrit dès le début en 2017
il a saisi l'opportunité d'un président
américain très unilatéraliste pour
revenir dans le multilatéralisme
donc c'est dans cette séquence laquelle
s'inscrit encore le voyage en afrique du
sud
il a ajouté un effet d'opportunité à
cette séquence il a profité de la crise
du coc vite pour très tôt s'est emparé
du sujet de la réponse sanitaire et de
la réponse économique on se souvient de
cette tribune qu'il avait signé avec un
certain nombre de chefs d'état africains
dès le début de la crise sanitaire et de
la prenais et de la réunion qu'elle
cyril ramaphosa l'avait confié biais
pour réfléchir avec les dirigeants
africains --le oms en réponse à donner à
cette crise inédite
mais la raison moi madiata lorsqu'il
parle de mea culpa de la parade emmanuel
macron rwanda nous ne perdons pas lésiné
à coup il a dit il a dit que toute façon
des excuses ne saurait peut-être même
passe assez forte
il a prononcé un discours de vérité
reconnaissant la responsabilité
politique dans les errances qui ont
conduit qui ont pu conduire au génocide
entre 90 et 1994
il est appuyé sur cela sur le travail
qui a été entrepris et c'est pour ça
qu'il a laissé toute liberté aux
chercheurs en
et rend les archives ils ont presque
toutes été libérées sol sauf celle de
l'assemblée nationale de l'époque et ses
chercheurs sur la base des informations
qu'ils ont trouvé aussi bien la dgse
qu'au ministère des affaires étrangères
que dans les archives mitterrand aussi
et de la présidence de la république ont
rendu chez le suspense un rapport assez
conséquent de près de 1200 1300 pages
qui explique bien les tenants et les
aboutissants cette crise et de cette
relation politique entre la france et le
régime de l'ancien président habyarimana
qui a pu conduire aux dérives que l'on
connaît on est riche donc un visiblement
dans une normalisation des relations
entre kigali et paris quel est l'intérêt
télé du rwanda mohammadia ta wii des
jeux j'allais juste rapidement dire que
je pense que si on prend la totalité du
discours de macron à kigali le mot mea
culpa me semble tout à fait juste parce
qu'il a simplement reconnu la
responsabilité qu avait joué la france
dans le génocide notamment par son
soutien à un gouvernement que l'on
savait par ailleurs génocidaire
l'importance de du rwanda en afrique
allait elle est diverse mais c'est
d'abord une importance en termes de
leadership parce que quand on regarde la
place que le rwanda occupe aujourd'hui
au plan géopolitique en afrique c'est un
pays petit par sa taille mais grand par
sa diplomatie pour le cam a su s'imposer
au niveau continental comme étant un
leader réformateur
notamment parce qu'il a pu accomplir
dans son propre pays au sortir du
génocide
c'est un pays qui se portent très bien
économiquement c'est un pays aussi
stable dans une région plutôt instable
celle des grands lacs et donc il ya ya
ya cette force à la voie économique mais
aussi géopolitique que le rwanda a sur
le continent est par ailleurs très
justement madiata à ce rapprochement
avec la france sur le plan économique
notamment
oui a effectivement aussi des
opportunités d'investissement aux rondes
1 étant donné que c'est une économie qui
se porte plutôt bien et qui veut se
diversifier qui veut avancer qui veut
continuer à 3 tressé d'un représente à
n'en point douter un marché aussi à
conquérir pour pour les entreprises
africaines
pascal airault on sent aussi un schéma
niall macron une certaine appétence pour
les pays anglophones on se souvient de
sa visite au nigeria en 2018 maintenant
le rwanda l'afrique du sud
est ce que nous voulons c'est réel
d'élargir finalement l' influence de la
france sur le continent qui est en perte
de vitesse et de d'élargir ce pré carré
quelques francophones pour l'instant je
crois fondamentalement que emmanuel
macron n'a pas envie de rester empêtré
dans une relation avec les pays de
l'ancien dauphin de lens coloniale
française lycéens banquiers s'étaient
pas performeur il voit une pique à l'est
au nigeria aussi innovante entreprenant
qui bouche et puis c'est aussi son stage
à l'ena c'est sa découverte de l'afrique
c'est vraiment nigeria il a découvert
l'afrique par les pays anglophones
donc il a envie d'aller vers cette
afrique là il sait qu'il ya des
opportunités énormes en matière de
business il sait qu'il y à des pays avec
des dirigeants qui sont très concernés
aussi par les questions multilatérales
comme il l'est comme il l'est
aujourd'hui
donc oui il ya une réelle appétence pour
aller vers des pays comme le kenya comme
comme comme l'ethiopie comme un nigeria
comme l'afrique du sud comme le
mozambique aussi l'afrique lusophone et
il ya de plus en plus aussi d' intérêts
français dans la région quand on voit
total qui investit 16 milliards au
mozambique total qui a des ambitions
d'exploration et de production
pétrolière et gazière aussi au large des
côtes de l'afrique du sud
et puis il ya tout aussi toute la
transformation énergétique qui est en
train de se mettre en place dans ces
régions avec des pays qui sont appelés à
voir des mix énergétique
là aussi un savoir faire il ya aussi des
choses à apporter dans le domaine des
infrastructures l'afrique du sud par
exemple ces 370 entreprises françaises
qui travaillent dans ce pays et c'est
une relation qui n'est pas marquée par
des relents anticoloniaux et où on peut
travailler sincèrement c mais cette
question à magath a du coup est ce que
la france a c'est finalement les reins
solides parce qu'il ya beaucoup de déjà
deux partenaires qui sont présents dans
cette partie du continent anglophones
les ophones la chine par exemple pour ne
citer qu'elles non je crois que la
france est déjà présente dans la région
et de moments un interlocuteur en face
la raclée la france est présente au
mozambique elle est présente au kenya
elle est évidemment présent dans
l'afrique du sud également mais je pense
qu'au delà de désintérêt économique et
social des régions stratégiques de se
rapprocher des pays qui en quelque sorte
sont les leaders sur le continent tels
que le nigeria mais aussi l'afrique du
sud parce que sur un plan multilatéral
mais aussi sur le plan continental avoir
des partenaires tels que l'afrique du
sud serait
naturellement bénéfique aux ambitions
que la france porte sur l'ensemble du
continent africain et la francophonie
dans tout cela on se souvient que son
prédécesseur françois hollande défendent
bec et ongles la francophonie est ce que
c'est une priorité aussi pour emmanuel
macron oui en quelque sorte mais ce qui
change avec ses prédécesseurs c'est pour
qu'il est il est pour une francophonie
assez ouverte
c'est à dire qu' une francophonie qui
peut aussi se nourrir des changes dans
dans d'autres langues et on le voit dans
le notamment dans la mise en place de
centres culturels francophones qui va
avoir lieu
acquis à kigali va y avoir des échanges
régionaux avec des artistes qui vont
venir de toute la région et qui vont
passer ça va pas être un centre culturel
français typique comme on a pu les voir
par le passé
oui je crois que la question du français
comme langue de courtage au delà du
cercle traditionnels des pays
francophones d'afrique est quelque chose
que emmanuel mccormack remporte
naturellement et d'ailleurs dans les
pays anglophones comme l'afrique du sud
au kenya
on a la présence de centres culturels
français où on y apprend la langue
française et donc je pense que
l'ambition aujourd'hui que porte
emmanuel mâcon me semble t'il en tout
cas c'est de faire en sorte que cela
soit intensifiée merci beaucoup à vous à
moi médiate analyste à l'institut
d'études de sécurité avoue pascal
airault journalistes à l'opinion
coauteur avec antoine glaser du livre le
piège africains de macron aux éditions
fayard